[Music]
on this Wednesday night top intelligence
officials grilled about foreign
interference we believe this threat is
on the rise as opposition parties
prepare to move a motion calling for a
national public inquiry
a convicted sex offender accused of
nearly 100 heinous crimes parents need
to be aware the tactics used to
allegedly lure dozens of children
tragedy on the tracks what's being
blamed for this deadly and disastrous
train crash in Greece plus Canada Soccer
Kicks off a new era by scoring a new
president
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Jeff Semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us the federal government is under
mounting pressure to launch a full
public inquiry into allegations of
foreign interference in Canada's
Democratic process the NDP now says it
will put forward a motion tomorrow
calling for the probe which conservative
MPS are expected to support the push
comes after weeks of reports from Global
News and the Globe and Mail outlining
beijing's alleged interference supping
the Prime Minister says his government
has taken great steps to address
this is one of those things that this
government has taken more steps on than
any previous government and we will
continue to take this issue extremely
seriously it's not a question of
partisanship or partisan game at gain as
we are seeing somewhere in some of the
comments out there
the prime minister's comments came as
MPS questioned top intelligence
officials on Parliament Hill over
allegations China covertly supported
candidates most of them liberals in the
2019 and 2021 election Mackenzie gray
has tonight's top story
another major call for a further look
into foreign interference it calls on
the government of Canada to launch a
national public inquiry into allegations
of foreign interference in Canada's
democratic system the NDP motion at the
House of Commons committee studying the
issue finding support from a political
foe it has to be public we can't simply
bury it behind closed doors and have it
in secret
while Canadians are left in the dark the
conservatives in NDP push for a public
inquiry comes after global news first
reported the Chinese Consul in Toronto
allegedly sent two busloads of Chinese
Canadian seniors to vote for current
level MP Han dong during his 2019
nomination meeting in Don Valley North
according to a combination of
intelligence sources and thesis
documents sources also say ceases
suspected the Chinese International
students with faked addresses were bused
in and told if they didn't support dong
they could lose their student visa dong
in the Liberal Party of Canada deny the
allegations and say the nomination rules
were followed but sources say ceases
warned senior Liberal Party of Canada
staff about Dong despite that Justin
Trudeau signed his nomination papers to
run for the liberal party today the
Prime Minister wouldn't say if he was
informed dong was an alleged thesis
Target we are constantly being engaged
with by our security agencies around how
to keep safe from foreign interference
true to his National Security advisor
would not discuss the substance of the
allegations against all I'm not going to
comment on information that was
inappropriately obtained the
concept and the problem and the severity
of foreign interference is well
documented interference that has become
more aggressive over the past five years
we believe this threat is on the rise
and increasingly complex
the greatest foreign interference threat
to Canada comes from the People's
Republic of China while the threats may
be rising the rcmps say they're not
reviewing any alleged interference from
2021. I can confirm that the uscmp is
not investigating any of the allegations
that are arising from the last election
the committee will decide tomorrow if it
will call for a public inquiry but the
vote is non-binding meaning will be up
to the Prime Minister and cabinet to
decide if they want to hold one and so
far Jeff Trudeau has resisted those
calls Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
Mac
and the new polls shows that a majority
of Canadians believe that China did
attempt to meddle in recent Federal
elections the survey from the Angus Reed
Institute found two-thirds of Canadians
say Beijing either definitely or
probably tried to interfere 53 feel the
Chinese government's alleged
interference attempts represent a
serious threat to democracy and more
than half say the liberal government has
not been strong enough in its response
to China and needs to do more to prevent
foreign meddling
the Prime Minister refusing calls for a
public inquiry pointed to those
committee hearings underway in Ottawa
and to a report released late yesterday
that looked at how the country dealt
with possible interference in the last
federal election our chief political
correspondent David Aiken has been
digging into that report so David what
does it tell us about any foreign
meddling in that 2021 election well I'll
tell you the Prime Minister believes
that that report tells us something the
latest review on 2021 just came out and
confirms that our election Integrity
held in 2021 as it did in 2019.
but it is not quite that clear-cut Jeff
that report that came out late Monday it
was not an investigation into
interference into Canada's overall
electoral process it was simply a review
of a process put in place for the
five-week long 2021 election the report
itself notes it cannot address
allegations of interference before the
campaign started such as in nomination
meetings or at any time outside that
very specific five-week election period
now those who want a public inquiry into
foreign interference they want to
examine activities before the election
campaign started again the report the PM
refers to only looks at some very narrow
procedural issues that happen during the
campaign now the report looked at a
system that gives five senior
bureaucrats the authority to decide
first if there has been a major incident
of election interference and then to
warn the public now in between between
elections that Authority rests with
elected officials the Minister of
Justice the minister of Public Safety
and so on but it would not be
appropriate during the actual election
to have politicians competing for votes
decide when or if to warn the public
about election interference so the
report concludes that those five
bureaucrats did their job well in 2021
and they did not detect major incidents
of interference the report also calls
for changes to make the system work
better to improve transparency to
improve Communications and to make
public minor incidents of election
interference and the report says the
government should start making those
changes right now so that the
bureaucracy political parties and most
of all voters are better prepared to
spot election interference and know how
to deal with it Jeff all right David
Aiken and Ottawa thanks David
a U.S intelligence investigation has
found it is very unlikely that a foreign
adversary was behind so-called Havana
syndrome cases that was the name used to
describe the strange symptoms
experienced by American and Canadian
diplomats and their families while
living abroad investigators looked at
1500 cases across 96 countries and they
found the illnesses appeared to have
different causes ranging from
pre-existing medical conditions to
environmental factors and didn't have a
common explanation reports of the
mysterious illnesses first surfaced in
2016 in Havana Cuba symptoms included
migraines nausea memory loss and
dizziness
a Toronto man is facing nearly 100
charges linked to a sexual assault
investigation involving children Daniel
Langdon is suspected of luring and
sexually assaulting victims as young as
Seven Police allege he targeted many of
them through social media and as Mike
drolets the accused was already known to
police and a warning some of the details
in this report are disturbing
this is a 31 year old Daniel Langdon
this too is Daniel Langdon as is this
pictures Toronto police say he altered
to appear younger on social media after
a lengthy and ongoing investigation
police have charged Langdon with 96
sexual offenses involving multiple
underage victims since April 2021 one
alleged incident involved a
seven-year-old victim who was sexually
assaulted at a Toronto Park Langdon
police say was prolific on social media
where he used pseudonyms on multiple
platforms including Snapchat Tick Tock
the teen dating app swiper and Instagram
where on one of his profiles he wrote
that he likes Friends Sunshine pizza and
ice cream we know that coming forward
isn't always easy
but we are asking anyone that may have
interacted with him or anyone that may
have any information to contact the
police Toronto police had previously
warned the public about Langdon in 2016
when he was arrested and eventually
convicted of charges related to child
pornography according to court records
accessed by global news he was sentenced
to two years less a day in jail and put
on the national sex offender registry
for life
but the registry which can only be
accessed by police is just a list and
once offenders are released from jail
they're often not tracked that's really
the problem here is we don't know how to
address this type of behavior
appropriately and how to manage it and
because that's really what it's about
you never
you never stop having sexual interest in
children it needs to be managed properly
and that he says puts the onus on
parents to please whom their kids speak
with online which can be a daunting task
the Canadian Center for Child Protection
reports its tip line has seen the number
of reported luring incidents rise from
220 in 2018 to 2013 in 2022. yeah I
would say that the the 815 percent
increase that we're seeing in the last
few years is staggering to us and the
real number when considering unreported
cases could be much higher microlay
Global News Toronto
BC and Saskatchewan are the latest
provinces to reach a deal with the
federal government over Health Care
funding BC has agreed in principle to a
27 billion dollar deal over 10 years it
includes a one-time 273 million dollar
Top-Up to help address urgent needs like
Pediatric Care Saskatchewan signed a six
billion agreement which includes a 61
million dollar Top-Up plus another 111
million dollars annually for the next
decade that money will be used to
improve access to Primary Care surgeries
and mental health and Addiction Services
the federal government is also setting
aside money to improve long-term care
it's promising nearly two billion
dollars over five years to increase
wages for personal support workers
another six billion dollar investment
with the provinces and territories will
help Home and Community Care the funding
is part of a 199 billion dollar Federal
commitment to improve health care over
the next 10 years
it's one of the worst crashes Greece has
ever seen
coming up the investigation into a fiery
collision between two trains
foreign
the Greek Prime Minister says human
error was largely to blame for a
horrific and deadly train crash north of
Athens at least 43 people were killed
and dozens of others injured last night
when a passenger train collided head-on
with a cargo train officials say both
were traveling along the same line for
several kilometers distraught family
members now wait at hospitals for news
of their loved ones many of those on
board were University students returning
after a long weekend a local train
station manager has now been arrested
and as Crystal commencing Reports
investigators are vowing to answer how
this tragedy could have happened
debris from a crash so unimaginable
officials on the ground could say little
other than to promise it would not
happen again
Tuesday night a passenger train emerged
from a tunnel near the vale of Tempe and
slammed head on into a cargo train
survivors say before the impact they
were traveling at roughly 160 kilometers
per hour
there was Panic for 10 15 seconds it was
chaos tumbling fires cables hanging
broken windows people screaming
we came down a fire erupted next to us
this man here he saw a hole so we
managed to get out
both trained conductors were killed
alongside dozens of passengers the
impact and Inferno that followed left
several carriages unrecognizable fire
officials say temperatures in those
burning cars Rose above 1 000 degrees
Celsius it's not known why the two
trains were traveling on the same line
we will investigate with complete
severity with complete transparency the
reason for this tragic incident the
transport minister of Greece distraught
at the scene later resigned out of
respect for the debt
this is believed to be the deadliest
rail incident in living memory in Greece
while touring the crash site the Prime
Minister said the first duty is to the
wounded and identifying the debt the
passenger train was traveling from
Athens to Thessaloniki with 352 people
on board
what we are experiencing today is very
very difficult as a country the train
company's website says it's the main
rail transporter for passengers and
Freight in the Country Canada has strong
ties to Greece with an estimated 270
thousand being of Greek descent the
bonds recognized in a condolence tweet
by prime minister Justin Trudeau
a three-day period of mourning is now
being observed in Greece
Crystal commencing Global News London
China is strengthening its ties with a
close Ally of Russia amid warnings from
Washington about the prospect of Beijing
providing weapons support to the Kremlin
the president of Belarus Alexander
lukashenka met with Chinese leader Xi
Jinping kicking off a three-day State
visit to Beijing the stated aim is to
strengthen a strategic partnership
lukashenka also backed China's so-called
peace plan for Ukraine it calls for a
ceasefire but not a Russian withdrawal
and condemns what it calls unilateral
sanctions Beijing also denies it plans
to provide lethal Aid to Moscow
please
and there are more signs that Ukrainian
forces may be on the brink of losing the
long bloody battle for the city of
bakmut in an interview an advisor to
Ukraine's President says its military is
weighing all options including a retreat
from the strategically important city
Ukrainian Fighters have held out against
a months-long offensive but the city is
now partly encircled by Russian troops
seizing back mood could open the way for
Russia to capture the rest of the
surrounding donbass region which was one
of the stated objectives of its mission
[Music]
rejecting results still ahead the
controversy surrounding the outcome of
Nigeria's federal election
[Music]
Israeli police cracked down on protests
in Tel Aviv firing stun grenades and a
water cannon to disperse demonstrators
protesters blocked the main Highway
between Tel Aviv and Jerusalem as part
of a nationwide day of disruption
against controversial judicial reforms
that would weaken the power of the
Supreme Court critics say the changes
are a threat to democracy
Africa's most populous country has a new
president-elect but the vote wasn't
without controversy Nigeria's Election
Commission announced a winner today in a
bitterly contested campaign and as Mike
Armstrong reports the parties that
finished second and third say they'll
contest the results in court
[Music]
he is moving from behind the scenes
kingmaker to president-elect Bola tinubu
is a former governor who helped his
party's leader win the last two
elections now he's won himself from my
heart
I say thank you very much
87 million people were eligible to vote
in this election according to the
Electoral commission tanubu finished in
first with just 8.7 million votes
turnout was low just 29
it is our position now two opposition
parties are rejecting the results the
labor party finished third but says
institutions of the state colluded to
return to new Boost party to power
Victory Labor's calling for a re-vote
saying the election wasn't transparent
free or fair but it says it will contest
the vote in court and called for
restraint while painful we implore you
all to please remain peaceful and calm
International observers say the
Electoral commission had serious
challenges insecurity in parts of the
country fuel shortages and major
technical problems all affected turnout
there's also new technology that was
supposed to make accounting and
tabulating easier and instead slowed
everything down
well tanubu says there weren't enough
problems to make a difference in the
results
Nigeria is Africa's biggest economy but
tanuba was set to take over a country
with multiple major crises
skyrocketing inflation poverty and
islamist insurgencies in the Northeast
but first he faces contested election
results after the weakest win in decades
Mike Armstrong Global News
fresh faces and a familiar challenge
next Canada Soccer looks to tackle
problems both on and off the field
thank you
welcome back as Canada's soccer deals
with bitter labor disputes over pay
equity and budget cuts it's making
changes at the top Charmaine Crooks was
promoted to acting president she's the
first woman and person of color to lead
the organization and Kelly Brown steps
into crooks's former role as the acting
vice president those changes come after
Nick bontes resigned as Canada soccer's
president and as Eric Sorensen explains
the new leadership will have to address
the push for a Level Playing Field
arguably the most successful period in
the country's soccer history has ushered
in the most tumultuous time governing
the sport the men's and women's national
teams are embroiled in a labor dispute
and there's mounting frustration over
funding their teams the president of
Canada's soccer Nick bontes finally
stepped down saying I acknowledge that
this moment requires change former
Olympian Charmaine Crooks who was vice
president of Canada Soccer has been
named acting president the first woman
and first person of color in the post in
a statement crook said I understand the
calls to get this right saying she will
build relationships and Trust across the
entire soccer ecosystem in Canada for
the Women's National Team it's also
about Equity they want the same
Financial backing for their World Cup
this year that the men got last year if
we are to promote
um equity in sport and women's sport we
need to put resources in that some would
call it an own goal by Canada Soccer the
organization lost the trust of the
women's and men's national teams at a
triumphant time for both for the women
the demand for fairness is backed by a
generation of success starting with the
under 19 team 20 years ago Canadian
women have been at or near the top two
bronze medals hosting the World Cup the
top scorer in the history of
international soccer and an Olympic gold
medal there is exponentially more money
in the men's game worldwide but in this
country soccer's popularity was spurred
by women right up until a few years ago
the Men's National Team in Canada was an
afterthought and the Women's National
Team you know were winning Olympic
medals they were capturing the hearts of
the nation and they were they were
fueling kind of the growth of the game
and the way that the Men's National Team
hasn't so I think that's where some of
the frustration comes there's also
frustration that Canada's soccer
negotiated corporate sponsorship and
broadcast agreements before the boom
times that now capped the amount that
Canada Soccer receives the players men
and women want Canada Soccer to open its
books there is no excuse for lack of
transparency and lack of accountability
Molina Peron believes Canada's soccer
and its next president have the
opportunity to come out of this crisis
and become a leader in gender equity and
accountability in sports governance Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Wednesday night I'm Jeff Semple
tonight's your Canada is this herd of
mountain sheep at Abraham lake near
Clearwater County Alberta thanks for
watching hope to see you back here again
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]